Tim Ferriss: Rich, it is a pleasure to have
you on the show.
Thank you for making the time.
Rich Paul: Thanks for having me, Tim.
Tim Ferriss: And I thought we would begin
with something that came up in my research
and that is R&J Confectionery.
Could you please explain for listeners what
R&J Confectionery was?
Rich Paul: R&J Confectionery was, to most
people, it was a store which my dad owned
and operated.
It was a community store, sat on the corner
of 125th and Edmonton on the east side of
Cleveland in the Glenville area.
For me, it was Harvard, Stanford, Penn.
That's what it was for me.
It was my curriculum, it was my education.
It was where I was molded and built and taught
so many different things just through interaction
and also what I would say was just being able
to observe as well.
Tim Ferriss: Now what types of things were
you observing?
What age were you when you first started spending
time there?
Could you just paint a picture for us?
Rich Paul: Yeah, I was very young.
I probably first started spending time in
the store when I was first able to walk, and
so a lot of the customers there watched me
grow up.
And over time, the neighborhood obviously
changed, and so there were great days, fun
days, where you were a little kid running
around the store helping picking out candy,
eating candy, playing with your friends.
And then there were days in which you started
to see a difference.
I started to see my friends' moms go from
this vibrant, beautiful person to strung out
on crack.
I saw young men go from playing sports to
now interacting and engaging in things as
an adult.
I saw a lot of violence, but at the same time,
it was where you got to observe and see how
people moved and people that you looked up
to or you thought were cool.
And so it was just this combustion of activity
throughout the day.
And my dad sat as the air traffic control
by him owning the store and things of that
nature.
And so I learned a lot of what to do.
I learned a lot of what not to do.
I had several influences, both good and bad,
several instances in which I was able to probably
experience some things and here's some conversations
that at that age you probably shouldn't.
But at the same time, when I look back on
it, I'm so glad I was able to because it really
put a lot of things in perspective, especially
for the seat I sit in now.
Tim Ferriss: On the cover of your book, I
believe you are around 14, 13 or 14 years
old?
Rich Paul: Yeah, that's correct.
Tim Ferriss: And I'm curious why you chose
that photo or that age for the cover?
Rich Paul: I think that's the age where in
life there's a fork in the road.
And I think for me, and it's just in my experience,
that's the age in which a lot of my friends
started off, started to go down a different
road.
And that's the age for us growing up where
you actually feel like you are an adult, "I'm
going to make this decision," you're held
accountable for the Muny League football games
and the baseball games and things like that
for some are not as exciting.
Now I want to make money, now I want to stay
out all night and just do certain things.
And so that was the age when I had several
pictures to choose from, but I chose that
picture because I think if you think about
even now in today's, especially in my community,
across America where I come from and all communities
like that, that age is just so important.
That's the age where you start to go down
one path or the other.
And I started losing a lot of friends around
that age.
Tim Ferriss: So let's hop to the present tense,
and we're going to go back to a lot of things
that I want to ask you about, including James
Baldwin, who is endlessly interesting and
fascinating to me.
But I would like to ask you about something
I know very little about, and that is the
free agency period.
So my understanding is that in the frantic
period that ensued this past July, you negotiated
something along the lines of close to $900
million worth of contracts.
And I would love for you just to give us a
behind-the-scenes glimpse of how you prepare
for that and what that type of process looks
like once the clock strikes and the game is
on.
What is that experience like for people who
don't have any familiarity?
Rich Paul: Well, for those who look at it
on ESPN or online, it's like, "Okay, it's
midnight July one, phone lines are open, everybody
can get to work."
For me and for us, my team, free agency doesn't
start July one in terms of your preparation.
You start prepping beginning of the year probably
before the season, summer league.
There's a lot of things that you need to prep
for.
There's a lot of posturing, there's a lot
of conversations, information, just watching
what other teams do as well as development
and giving your guy some insights, as well,
so he can position himself better and understand
what the team is looking for or whatnot.
And so by the time you get to July, you pretty
much have a decent board.
There could be some times you don't know and
there's teams pop up out of nowhere.
But once that hits, now you're taking meetings
with different teams.
And if you're lucky enough to have a guy that
has multiple teams, then he's trying to decide
what fits best for him and his family on one
end, and then you're trying to decide a number
on the other end with that team.
And so it's pretty hectic.
It's a lot that comes with it.
I know it looks easy, but it's not easy and
—
Tim Ferriss: It doesn't look easy.
Rich Paul: And we were blessed to reach that
number.
And I'm still in negotiations right now with
a couple of guys, and so it never ends.
Tim Ferriss: So when you're doing the prep
and you say when you have a decent board,
and again, I apologized before we started
recording, but I'm coming in very uneducated
with this type of thing.
I just don't have the familiarity.
I followed a few sports, but mostly boxing
and fight sports.
So with that in mind, what does it look like
to have a decent board in front of you in
terms of what you've decided or strategy or
anything else?
What does that look like?
Rich Paul: When you talk about a decent board,
I'm speaking about the options that you may
have based upon the players you represent.
This year we had a number of players that
were sought after by a number of different
teams.
And so when you have those options, that's
incredible.
Any agent will tell you that's very hard to
do.
And then it's just a matter of getting things
done in a timely manner.
Teams, one thing about it, teams like to be
able to move.
And so if you are moving your feet slow, they
have to jump to somebody else.
Very few people, team's going to wait on,
very few people team's going to wait on.
And so when you do have somebody that teams
are actually going to wait on, you also have
to balance that too because you want to be
respectful to them as well and their time.
And so I try not to string people along.
At the end of the day, you have to give yourself
time, but there's definitely a balance.
Tim Ferriss: So I'd love to get into maybe
a story or some specifics of the negotiating
process because, by all accounts, you're considered
a master negotiator.
And I'll give one example, maybe if you could
speak to this.
How did information that you received negotiating
for Draymond Green's contract, which I think
was four years, 100 million, inform how you
then approached the market for Jerami Grant,
which ended up being five years, 160 million?
I'm just wondering how things —
Rich Paul: Actually, Jerami's was done before
Draymond's.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, okay, great.
So let's —
Rich Paul: Jerami's was done before Draymond's.
But to answer your question, Draymond was
in a much different situation than Jerami.
Obviously he's older, he's been on the team,
one team for 11 years at the time.
He's a guy that his stats may not necessarily
show his value, but when you plug him somewhere,
he brings a tremendous value.
He brings a championship experience, a chip.
He's one of the smartest guys on the court
every night.
And so when you're negotiating for somebody
like Draymond, analytics and all those things
don't really matter.
In Jerami's case, we had already understood
what was happening in Portland and with their
star player at that time, but we also kept
the conversation, the communication, to understand
that they valued Jerami there as well, regardless
what was going on with their star player.
So that was great to know.
And then there were some other teams around
the league that anybody can use a six nine
athletic wing like Jerami, versatile, the
whole nine.
And it was a matter of if he wanted to stay
in Portland, despite what may have taken place.
And so, he did.
And he had other teams with cap space that
would actually spend the money.
Where Draymond was a little bit different.
In order to get to his number, there was very
few teams with the cap space to do that.
So now you've got to look at a sign and trade,
which we had a sign and trade lined up.
But ultimately Draymond wanted to stay with
the Warriors.
That's where he was drafted, that's where
he's had success.
And so at that point, you just have to turn
and make the best deal with the team that
he was on.
So that's what I was able to do.
Tim Ferriss: I'd like to, and this may be
pushing for a tie-in, but I'm curious what
type of gambling you were referring to when
you were younger.
So when you were a kid?
Rich Paul: Yeah, we gambled on everything.
If two people had a discrepancy, the next
word was bet.
And so that was my mentality since I was seven,
eight years old.
And so my dad taught me how to shoot dice
and play cards.
And then that led to horseshoes or betting
on any sports that you were capable of doing,
whether it was racing from end to end or whether
you decided to shoot jumpers at the park from
the top of the key like you would see on White
Men Can't Jump.
We really did that at our park, and I practiced
it to the point to where I perfected it to
where I could shoot with one hand.
And so allowing me to, if I'm betting a guy
and I'm going to shoot with one hand, then
his bet has to be more than my bet because
I'm at a disadvantage, so to speak.
So everything we did, whether it was ping
pong, it didn't matter what it was shooting
pool, I didn't want to play pool unless we
were betting.
I didn't want to bowl unless we were betting.
And so I just had that mentality growing up
that just everything was about a bet.
So that's the type of gambling.
That was street gambling prior to me playing
in the casino.
But I don't really gamble as much at the casino
as I would in the streets.
It's a totally different vibe for me.
Tim Ferriss: So what are some of the things
that made you effective in street gambling?
And were there any particular games that were
your specialty or types of bets?
You mentioned the shooting.
Rich Paul: Yeah, shooting dice.
I was special.
Like Steph Curry has a great three-point shot,
I had a great shot.
I was the Steph Curry of dice shooting, for
sure.
But there's also a confidence.
And there was also, for some weird reason,
I felt like I can actually talk to the dice,
and they could speak to me.
It was my pet, everyone has a dog or a teddy
bear.
The dice was my pet.
I would go around and just gamble.
I would gamble against anybody.
It didn't matter who it was.
I would shoot dice against my grandmother
if she had some money and wanted to bet.
And that was just my mentality.
So it was great.
It was good though, but it was dangerous at
times.
And I think about it all the time sometimes.
Just being behind abandoned buildings or in
the basement of an abandoned house and you've
got this money and for things to go the way
they went for me, I'm extremely lucky.
Tim Ferriss: And if we come back to the free
agency period, I'm curious if, for instance,
if you were for whatever reason sidelined
and you had to coach someone to step in your
place to have a lot of the conversations,
to do a lot of the planning that you're talking
about, are there any key pieces of advice
that you might give them or warnings that
you might give them?
"Do not do this.
I tried this once.
It's a bad idea."
Any advice that you think would be key?
Rich Paul: There's several things.
You've got to really watch out for friendly
fire.
There's a ton of friendly fire out there.
Friendly fire in terms of giving too much
information to somebody, and then they share
that information, not knowing who they're
sharing it with.
And it comes back to it backfires on you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, bite you in the ass.
Rich Paul: Yeah, that happens a lot.
You've got to prepare.
We've seen things happen this year with guys,
and it is not necessarily their fault.
They wasn't prepared.
You're going into a meeting with somebody,
you have to know pretty much what they're
looking for and being able to try to feel
the answer to the test already.
Patience, can't panic, you can't take any
of it personal, it's not a personal thing.
And I always say some people define the business
card and some people are defined by their
business card, and so I don't carry a business
card.
So it puts things in perspective for you.
But ultimately, every year I learn something
new.
I'm a sponge man.
I like to be educated.
I have a different temperament than most would
probably have, and at the end of the day,
you're only going to be as strong as your
client.
If you have a strong client, they trust you
and they are aligned.
Then I've been in situations where a deal
got done in one day, and I've been in situations
where it took three and a half months and
I was fine with either one.
Tim Ferriss: How did you first meet LeBron?
Rich Paul: We met in the airport, Akron County
Airport.
Tim Ferriss: And what was the way in which
you guys met?
Did you go up to him?
Did he say something to you?
Rich Paul: I had a jersey.
I had a Warren Moon Oilers jersey on that
kind of caught his attention, and then he
asked me about the jersey and that's what
started the conversation.
And then that led to us kind of bumping into
each other again at the baggage claim.
And I gave him my business card because at
the time I did have a business card and I
was selling our jerseys to a store that he
can go to locally in Atlanta.
And then when he got back to Ohio, they reached
out to me again and then that kind of started
the relationship.
Tim Ferriss: How did the relationship evolve
from that point?
Rich Paul: I think just when I was young,
again, my life had really gave me so many
different tools and experiences and so when
you're a young kid like they were, I had all
the things.
I had the clothes, I had the jewelry, I had
the car, I had the know-how, I had the confidence,
I had the experience, and we would just talk.
But I think the thing that drew us together
and closer was our moms.
I was able to see him and observe things and
have conversations with him where he could
be himself and not feel the need to protect
himself because I was going through the same
thing or I had gone through the same thing.
And so that's what really brought us closer
together.
Tim Ferriss: Was the family similarity?
Rich Paul: Yeah, family similarity.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I know I'm bouncing around a
lot, but that's sort of the nature of my mind.
I'm trying to tease out some of the influences
or models that you've had.
I know you have portraits of a number of different
people, and I understand one of those is James
Baldwin.
And I was wondering if you could just explain
what the significance is of James for you
or why you're attracted to him.
Rich Paul: Obviously, I didn't grow up with
him in that space, but just watching old videos
and things like that, just what he stood for,
how articulate he was, how he saw things and
broke it down and the way he did it.
I think it's important to really pay homage
to people like that.
That room that picture's in, I have a number
of people from entertainers to activists to
actors from some of my favorite movies, both
mob movies and movies that was created by
the John Singleton and Hughes brothers and
so on and so forth, as well as just different
legends in music and sports.
That's a room of inspiration for me.
But James Baldwin in particular, at a time
where it wasn't popular to be as blunt as
he was, it wasn't ideal for someone who looked
like him to be as smart and articulate as
he was and not just on the surface, but in
depth.
That moved me and that was somebody that I
felt like I wanted to have on my wall.
Tim Ferriss: I encourage everybody who's listening,
if you are not familiar with the name, look
up James Baldwin.
I mean, so brilliant.
So, as you mentioned, articulate and also
very good at presenting the messiness of life
in a way that wasn't over-indulgent, but very
truthful and bold, like you mentioned.
And had a very complicated life himself, like
a lot of people.
But I've collected quotes of his for the last
year or two, just an incredible depth of character.
So I encourage people to check out James Baldwin,
if you haven't already.
You have been incredibly successful in a world
that on some level, at least at points has
prioritized or highlighted formal degrees.
But how how has that lens affected you?
Rich Paul: Well, I finished high school at
a very high level.
I just didn't need college.
I actually made an attempt to go to college
and I actually enjoyed school.
I really did, but my life was different and
for what I needed to do, I felt like I was
prepared.
My dad did an unbelievable job in my environment,
did an unbelievable job of preparing me, and
equipping me with the tools necessary for
me to persevere through life.
I think society paints the picture that you
need a higher education for certain things,
and I think that when you go to get a job,
they go by what your education status is,
which again, for some jobs I understand it,
but most kids that graduate college, they're
not working in their field that they got a
degree in anyway.
So I don't know how much of a — that actually
added —
Tim Ferriss: Indicator, it is.
Yeah.
Rich Paul: Yeah.
But I always felt prepared, especially for
what I do for sure.
Tim Ferriss: So at some point, and again,
this is me just looking at some reading in
the process of preparing for this, but the
NCAA announced a rule at one point that agents
could not represent college athletes unless
they themselves had a college degree.
Now at face value, that seems ridiculous.
And then LeBron dubbed on Twitter, this particular
regulation, the hashtag, the Rich Paul rule.
Why do you think they tried to put this into
action, and how did they justify it also?
Rich Paul: There was really no justification.
I think they tried to put it into action to
prevent the next Rich Paul because it wasn't
about — as much as it was about me, it wasn't
nothing they could actually do to me, but
they could discourage someone else.
And it's no different than, again, you have
to have a college degree to become this person.
Well, if you look at it and if you do the
data, that basically carves out a specific
group of people that are going to be given
opportunity based upon the completion of a
higher education.
Because one thing about life, life don't always
afford you to pay attention to higher education,
especially when you grew up the way I did
in terms of — and I know people had it worse
than I did.
So when you talk about just trying to survive
and trying to survive the day, the week, the
month, younger siblings and lights are off,
gas is off, it is just a different dynamic,
and it's unfair in a lot of ways because you
basically feel trapped a lot of times.
And so I feel like again, that's just a discouragement
and that's just an excuse to be able to say
why you didn't give somebody an opportunity
because they didn't have this.
But I think there's more people that can actually
learn on the job training, unless it's something
like you have to code at Microsoft or Apple
or you have to — and even that, there's
geniuses that learn this stuff at home.
They're not learning it from a textbook.
And so I just think it's all bullshit to be
honest with you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I think it seems like people
came around on it to, whether they like to
or not, end up on the same page.
What would you say are any of the best investments
you've made?
And I'll explain what I mean.
Because you have taken a very unorthodox path
to get to where you are, but you have studied
and you've learned and observed like you mentioned,
from a very young age.
And so for instance, I'll just give a couple
examples.
Like Warren Buffett would say one of his best
investments, maybe his best investment, was
taking a public speaking course, Dale Carnegie,
because it amplified everything he was able
to do.
A lot of people on the podcast have put time
into something or energy into something that
paid dividends later.
What have been some of the best investments
of time or energy or money that you've put
in in terms of something that laid the ground
for something that happened later, if that
makes any sense?
Rich Paul: For me, it was the dry runs.
Getting out on that road, driving to get in
front of a family and coming up short.
I think it really allows you to decide if
this is something you really want to do.
And if so, now I have to figure out ways to
get better because I didn't play the money
game.
When I got into this business, I didn't play
the money game.
I didn't play the cut-your-fee game.
I didn't do any of that.
All the stuff that's still going on now, I
didn't do that.
And I was up against the bigger agencies that
had the perception, the cache, and they had
the alliances within these universities and
things like that to help them, give them information,
give families the number or give the number
of families and then sit up a kid in a room
and tell them — don't tell them not to go
somewhere because they don't want that on
them, but they will tell them why they should
go here.
So now when you call the coach, they say,
"Well, I didn't tell them not to come with
you."
But you didn't tell them they should either,
but you told them they should for this company
that you happen to be represented by and stuff
like that.
And so I had to deal with all those type of
things and navigate my way around that, which
I did.
But that was one of the best investments for
sure.
And then I think the other thing was just
kind of investing in self, knowing that and
believing that despite the shortcomings, just
stay at it.
It'll turn.
And again, in the dice game, we used to have
to be able to say, "Can you stand the rain?"
A guy is throwing point after point after
point and you would have to stand in there
and stand the rain and eventually they turn
and things go the other way, so I was prepared.
Tim Ferriss: So when you mentioned you weren't
playing the money game, do you mean that you
were not cutting your fees as a way to try
to make yourself more attractive?
Could you say a bit more about that?
Rich Paul: Yeah.
Not cutting my fees is a way to make — because
people don't believe in your work practice
and your expertise.
And then the bigger companies, they're able
to do that because they're just rolling it
all into their annual revenue, so if you've
got —
Tim Ferriss: Right, the larger machine.
Rich Paul: Yeah, 25 different verticals.
Okay, so sports is one of them, and you roll
it into it and then they look at it as we'll
charge the higher less, we'll charge the middle
more and we'll charge the lower the max and
they'll be appreciative to be here because
we probably shouldn't be representing them
anyway.
And then we'll roll it all up and at the end
of the day, it goes on our books and what's
dead is dead.
I have a clear understanding of the business,
but when you are on your own, you don't have
that.
You can't do that.
And so I was able to get players despite that,
and it actually drove them crazy and still
does to this day.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I bet it drove them crazy.
So what were your selling points?
Because the big agencies have all of the stuff
that we could probably guess they would use
to sell.
We've got all this coverage, we've got all
these verticals, we can expand in these following
ways, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
What did you find over time as you're putting
in reps and learning, after coming up short
and then improving, what were your main selling
points that allowed you to get some of those
key early folks?
Rich Paul: I think there was a genuineness.
They can feel that in the room.
There was an actual real care for who they
were as individuals and as families.
I just thought different — I led with education.
I wasn't selling anything because I found
out very early, there's nothing to sell.
You can go in with your PowerPoint, back in
the day we put the CD in and show all these
other people that the company represented,
but the reality was those people were never
going to touch those people.
Those people don't actually care about the
people that's in this room.
So you're showing that as if it's all at one
family and it's not.
And so I just really shined a light on that,
and the people that gave me an opportunity,
I did right by them, which got me the next
opportunity.
Tim Ferriss: You've said in a GQ interview,
which had a great title, "Rich Paul: Power
Broker of the Year," that one of the biggest
obstacles for young players in learning how
to become a pro or be a pro is establishing
infrastructure.
What do you mean by infrastructure?
Rich Paul: Most guys, that's athletes especially,
they've come from an environment to where
everyone along the way has made it about them.
And so if you have the mentality that it's
only about me, then you're not going to value
other people and what their capabilities are,
what their expertise is.
But if you are a walking corporation, we can't
name one corporation that does not have infrastructure.
Organization.
They have an organizational chart, they have
people that do certain things and there's
clarity within that infrastructure, but it
comes with the costs.
And so most athletes don't want to do what?
They don't want to pay anybody to do anything
because along the way, everyone has did things
for them for free, but it wasn't really for
free.
It was to be able to be standing there next
to them at a time where there was actually
something to gain.
So I'll sacrifice this now when you're an
amateur to be able to stand next to you to
get some crumbs or whatever the case when
you become a pro.
And whatever their aspirations were, if it
was to hang out, the girls, to travel, whatever
it is, the money, whatever it was, but you
see what they did.
Basically, you created something that ultimately
became your own demise because up front you
taught them wrong.
You taught them, "I'm doing this out of love.
I'm going to pick you up, I'm going to do
this, I'm going to do that."
All to turn it around on them when they start
making money and say, "Remember when I did
this or I did that?"
Well, that's not fair to the player, and it's
also not fair to yourself.
What the conversation should be like is, "Look,
I understand you don't have the ability to
pay for anything, and if you're a parent,
I'm doing it out of love.
I love you.
You're my kid."
But if you're somebody else, just be honest
with it.
"Hey, look, I'm going to do all I can to help
you get to where you need to go.
Once you get there, if there's an opportunity
for me, then I'm going to do all I can to
position myself to where if you give me that
opportunity, I can then be of value to you."
Very simple.
Tim Ferriss: When free isn't free, right,
it's an unclear prepayment for things to come
later, that's when it seems like things can
get extremely messy.
How do you help them when they, say, sign
with you, or even just start to develop a
relationship with you, to take the first steps
for building out infrastructure?
What are some of the first steps that you
might recommend?
Rich Paul: I would say checks and balances.
Really getting the proper financial team in
place, and that's everybody from a CPA to
the guy who manages your investment portfolio
or the company that manages your investment
portfolio.
Really having somebody monitor that because
that's a very fragile thing there.
But at the same time, deciding what it is
that you want.
I like to live a certain way now that I understand
better on how to live.
And so if you are a single man with no family,
do you really need a 20,000 square foot home?
Probably not.
You're not going to be home half the time.
Do you really need to fly private?
Probably not.
So there's different ways to go about it,
but what's most important?
Should you hire a chef?
Yes, you should.
Should you take a shortcut on that?
No, you shouldn't.
Do you know the difference between a chef
and a cook?
You should find that out because this is very
important.
Your chef should then go and sit with your
nutritionist on your team and figure out.
You should do all the testing, everything
you need, because your body ultimately is
the engine that keeps you running.
That's how you make your money.
Tim Ferriss: What are some of the key ingredients
for emotional support and stability?
I'm just imagining young athletes who are
suddenly in the limelight, they have all the
temptations, they have a lot of pressure.
There must be, and I know a few professional
athletes who've gone through these periods,
periods that are very challenging, and certainly
after retirement or the end of their playing
years, some very challenging times.
What have you seen in terms of the best ways
to support that?
Could be from your side, it could be other
ingredients, player, health on that side of
the ledger.
Rich Paul: Yeah.
I think nowadays, I think there needs to be
someone that players need to talk to and be
open-minded to having a therapist to get stuff
off their chest because they deal with a lot.
They deal with a lot.
I think it's also important for players to
not feel entitled to do things.
Oftentimes, they feel like they have to take
on all of this onus to do something for other
people, and that's not real.
Because when it comes down to it, if you ask
probably 80 percent of the players that aren't
in the position they used to be in and ask
them who can do for them, there's not going
to be many, if any for that matter, and so
—
Tim Ferriss: Meaning people who —
Rich Paul: People, yeah —
Tim Ferriss: — are willing to help them?
Rich Paul: Yeah, of course.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Rich Paul: Then how are they positioning themselves
to where when the ball stops, it's not about
just having a ton of money like, "How can
I do something else?
How can I be perceived, while playing, as
someone who can transition and do something
else?"
There's this idea that, "Oh, I made a lot
of money, I don't have to do nothing else."
Well, that's not true because you made a lot
of money, but you didn't diversify your portfolio.
Unless your money is making money for you
and you live a lifestyle in which your eight
percent or your 10 percent or whatever it
is return each year is able to pay your bills
and your taxes on your home and stuff like
that, then you've got to go to work.
You have to go to work.
It's a big difference when you've made $50
million this year and then next year you made
nothing.
It's just tough.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
What do you say to the players when they start
to take on that onus you were mentioning,
right?
So people come to them and ask them for things,
I'm sure it happens all the time from many
different directions, from people they've
met along the way, from new people.
When you see someone who's about to take on
too much or accept that, what does that conversation
look like?
Rich Paul: If they come to me with the conversation,
it's very real.
I don't really have a lot of gray in me.
It's pretty black and white.
Even though I have a gray Klutch Athletics
hoodie, it's pretty black and white for me
because that's how life is.
Life is, there's no gray in it, man.
Outside of the days, 300 of the days in Cleveland,
Ohio, that's great, but there's no real gray
in it, man.
I just want them to understand how important
it is to get their ducks in a row at their
youngest age, because that's when they make
their money at their youngest age.
The average person makes their money between
the age of 45 and 65.
The average athlete makes their money between
the age of 19 and 25, maybe 30 if they get
that far.
It's so hard.
Then learning when to jump off that dream
train, right?
Yes, I know you thought you was going to be
a Hall of Famer.
You thought you was going to be an all-NBA
guy.
You thought you was going to play 15 years
in the league, but if you play two or three
or five, save your money.
Do the things while playing to learn how this
business actually operates and start to position
yourself to where I can still be around the
game in a different form.
When you look at guys, and there's a reason
why top coaches aren't really ex-players or
ex-star players, let me say that, ex-star
players because they wasn't allowed to have
the ego that most star players have, and so
they actually become better coaches.
When you look at a Ty Lue, when you look at
a guy like Adrian Griffin, who's getting the
opportunity now in Milwaukee, well deserved,
overly deserved.
When you look at guys like Quin Snyder, who—
Quin played ball, he was a good player.
He wasn't John Stockton, right?
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Rich Paul: But he's a hell of a coach, and
he's going to make more money as a coach than
he would as a player.
Ty Lue has already done it.
Darvin Ham's going to do it.
When you really think about this, because
I studied this stuff, it's a guy like Jamahl
Mosley.
He tried to play ball and played ball a little
bit, but whatever.
But as a coach, he's going to be — but he
paid his dues, went from development to this
to that, and just have the time.
Give yourself time and be patient, and do
the little things necessary to continue to
reposition yourself and it's going to happen
for you.
That can be any part of the ecosystem of sport,
in any sport for that matter.
Tim Ferriss: So you mentioned ego, and I'd
love to focus on this for a second because
it seems like LeBron has never been known
as someone who's ego-driven.
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this, of
course, but as someone that talented and that
driven, obviously putting in intense amounts
of work and dedication, one could imagine
a world in which a person like that would
be very ego-driven, and certainly there are
counter examples.
What do you think it is that has led him to
be that way, or is he just that way right
out of the box?
Rich Paul: I think he's that way.
But also, LeBron's from Akron, Ohio.
If you've ever been to Akron, there's not
much there.
So there wasn't these things that allowed
him to develop this ego, per se.
When you think about his friends, same guys
he went to high school with, same guys he
go back with now.
Yeah, he's LeBron, but they don't give a — they
still talk crazy to him, and they talk about
things and they laugh and joke or whatever
and fall out and get back together.
That's just life.
Then when you think about his business infrastructure,
myself, Maverick, Randy, et cetera, we don't
really care that he's LeBron, per se.
He values our opinion, we value him.
If we have a discrepancy or disagreement or
something, we're not going to hold our tongue
because he's LeBron, and that's one aspect
of it, but that's not even what's the most
important.
The most important thing in all of that, though,
is he's not going to look at it as if he can
overpower or just do something for the sake
of doing it because he is LeBron.
See, it takes two to tango, and that has helped
him along the way.
We all have disagreements in meetings and
so on and so forth, but one thing about him,
he's egoless enough to know when he should
listen.
That's just showing people respect and believing
in them, and so I think that's helped him
tremendously.
Now, we all have ego.
Don't get me wrong, you have to have an ego
to have confidence, but you're not invested
in your ego.
You're not leading with the ego.
You know when the ego is supposed to come
out the room and when it's not.
When he's at that—I still call it the Staples
Center—he has an ego.
He's LeBron James.
That's his show.
That's his stage.
He's there to perform and put on a great show,
sometimes too great of a show if you ask me.
I would like him to be a little bit more precise
with things, and we debate about that as well.
Tim Ferriss: I'd like to talk about how you
think about luck.
So the name of your memoir is Lucky Me.
Rich Paul: Mm-hmm.
Tim Ferriss: Why Lucky Me?
Rich Paul: Why Lucky Me?
Look, when you think about it, I grew up in
my dad's store.
I learned math through playing the numbers
and selling beer, wine, cigarettes, et cetera,
candy.
I was extremely lucky to have that environment.
I was extremely lucky to have a dad who believed
in me enough to stress education and to teach
me things in which that he knew I was going
to need to be successful in life; not successful
for the moment, but successful for the duration,
and success not necessarily meaning from a
finance perspective, but just from a humanity
perspective, extremely lucky.
I was extremely lucky to go through some of
the things that I went through to help shape
me and mold me to understand life's challenges
and to be able to survive those thunderstorms
emotionally and things like that, to get out
on the other side.
So in addition to Jay-Z's Lucky Me being my
favorite record, there's a number of things
that I was extremely lucky for.
I was able to make it out of an environment
to where many didn't.
When I say they didn't, not because they're
dead or in jail, but because mentally, they
just can't see past what's in front of them.
I'm extremely blessed and lucky to be able
to do so to the point to where it's gotten
me this far.
At the same time, it's a little sarcasm to
it because look, I didn't have my mom.
I didn't have many options.
My entrepreneurial spirit led me down the
road of what some would say was detriment
and darkness.
At the same time, I was able to persevere
through it.
So there's a number of meanings in between
it or amongst it, but ultimately, I felt that
was the right title.
Tim Ferriss: A great title.
Could you say a bit more about the entrepreneurial
impulse leading you into darkness, if I heard
you correctly?
Can you say a bit more about that chapter?
Rich Paul: Growing up, we had very little
options.
If you had an entrepreneurial spirit, you
only could be that entrepreneur through hustles.
That hustle could have been everything from
selling jerseys to selling drugs, selling
candy to selling inner tubes from a bike or
everything was a hustle.
There was no real jobs.
There was no real understanding of corporate
America.
There was no opportunities and there was no
examples, more importantly, to see someone
go to work every day, get a raise, get promoted,
and then go from being promoted, get promoted
again, and then become partner.
We didn't have these examples that I have
today.
Tim Ferriss: We flash back because it seems
like, at least based on some of the notes
I have in front of me, one of the through
lines for you, one of the themes is, possibly,
"How you do one thing is how you do everything."
I wanted to ask about creasing and ironing
your jeans as a kid.
Is that something that you did?
If so, why did you do that?
Rich Paul: My sister taught me how to iron
my jeans first and foremost.
Then once she taught me, it made me feel like
I was an adult at a very young age.
Then I started to decide that there's the
detail in it and ironing my jeans the way
I did and having the creases line up, and
then I perfected that.
Then from there, I realized that, "Oh, I can
iron really good."
So I started to advertise my ability to iron.
So when I would go to my uncle's house or
somebody's house and they're getting dressed
to get ready to go to the bar or the club,
and they can't do two things at once.
So I say, "Hey, I'll iron your clothes for
you, and there's going to be a charge for
that."
I made money ironing clothes with no problem.
I think that the detail of it and my preciseness
of it allowed them to trust me more.
The more they trusted me, the more I can charge.
So now ironing jeans is one thing, but if
I'm ironing silk pants or a silk shirt and
I knew how to adjust the iron to wool and
linen and so on and so forth, and I built
a good business, and I made money every which
way like that.
But then me understanding that and willing
and wanting to align those creases properly
and take my time to do it and prepare as such
with the iron and the water and light starch
and things like that, that quote that you
made, "How you do one thing is how you do
everything," that's at its foundation and
your approach to it.
Because whatever arena you're in, just your
approach to that, that detail, staying that
detail-oriented will allow you to progress.
So that's what that meant.
Tim Ferriss: Usually, I wouldn't ask about
something in the background, but I have to
ask, what is the polar bear statue in the
background behind you?
Looks like a polar bear.
Rich Paul: Oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah, that's just
interior design.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
I have a thing for polar bears, that's why
I was asking.
Rich Paul: Yeah, but that's an Ernie Barnes
behind me, that picture.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Rich Paul: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So can you tell me more about
the Ernie Barnes piece?
You seem like somebody who chooses things.
I imagine these things aren't just thrown
in your house.
Rich Paul: Oh, no.
No, they're placed properly.
Ernie Barnes is a well-known Black artist.
He's most known for the cover of Marvin Gaye's
album and —
Tim Ferriss: I recognize the style.
I've never seen that piece, but I recognize
the style.
Rich Paul: The picture at the end of Good
Times, that painting is called "The Sugar
Shack."
Eddie Murphy actually owns the original one
from my understanding, and I was fortunate
enough to be able to purchase this piece.
This is called "The Runway."
So growing up, I watched Good Times a lot,
didn't know anything about art, saw that picture
the whole time.
Then as I got more into art, I started to
learn different artists, and Ernie Barnes
was somebody I wanted to make sure I had in
my collection.
Tim Ferriss: What is player empowerment?
What does that mean?
Rich Paul: Player empowerment, I know that
people use this a lot, but it's really player
choice.
I think that oftentimes people say as player
empowerment, you get confused with like, "Oh,
a player can just do whatever they want."
No, that's not the case.
I think player empowerment comes through the
lens of education, understanding that you
do have a choice, flexibility, and just having
a mindset that "I don't necessarily have to
play my career or put my career on the same
track as somebody else's because that's what
the media or anybody around my game would
expect me to do."
And the example of that is Reggie Miller was
a great player.
He spent his whole time with the Indiana Pacers.
Dirk Nowitzki was a great player.
He spent his whole time with the Mavericks.
Kobe was a great player, he spent his whole
time with the Lakers.
But LeBron and KD are great players.
They've been on several teams.
That doesn't make them any lesser than a legend
or icon as those other guys that just named.
But because these people get on these media
platforms and try to create a narrative of
what's right and what's wrong and how something
should go versus how it shouldn't.
No, everybody's career and their journey is
their journey.
But I think it's a misconception with player
empowerment because it's not like they can
write their own checks or their own teams.
So it's only so much power within that empowerment.
But I think the empowerment is for players
to give, to empower other players to do as
you feel necessary within the lines of your
professional positioning and obviously your
contract, but don't feel the need to have
your journey look like someone else's.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, self-authoring with choice
and educated choice, like you mentioned.
Who were the most important influences in
developing your confidence?
Rich Paul: Again, going back to my dad, first
and foremost.
My brother, who even to this day, when I called
my brother about something, he's like — and
I'll be talking to him like, "Bro, I'm thinking
about doing this and what do you think?
I think it may work."
He's like, "Bro, it's going to work.
I've been telling you this since you was a
kid.
It's going to work.
Don't even worry about it."
This is his exact conversation.
But outside of family, I've had a lot of people
that instilled confidence in me.
My Uncle Warren when I played mini football,
they would put the confidence in you.
You may not like the words, but you know that
they instill the confidence in you.
Tim Ferriss: What kind of things might he
say?
How did he do that?
Rich Paul: Who?
My brother and my Uncle Warren?
Tim Ferriss: Your uncle.
Yeah.
Rich Paul: I mean, I played quarterback when
I was a Muny League football player, or if
I switched to receiver or safety.
He would just, "You know what you're supposed
to do, you know how to do it.
We worked on it.
You know what we practice on, you can do it."
And that was the mentality.
We had the expectation of when Belichick was
leading the Patriots, when the Patriots were,
if they didn't want to go to the Super Bowl,
it was a failed season.
That was our mini league team.
If we did not go to the city championship,
something was wrong.
And so you go into practice with that understanding
and that mentality and that expectation on
you, that's what it was.
And even when I was young, gambling, shooting
dice, my dad would instill that confidence
in me.
I've had some unbelievable comeback.
You think the Cavs came back from 3-1, you
don't know what it's like to have a hundred
dollars and you down to your last dollar and
you're 11 years old and you've got $1 left,
and you turn that dollar into 200, you roar
all the way back.
It's the —
Tim Ferriss: Redemption trail.
Rich Paul: For sure.
It's an unbelievable feeling to do that.
And I had plenty of nights like that, whether
it was on the basketball court or whether
it was at the dice game, and I think about
those moments all the time.
Those were some fun times, man.
It really was.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Yeah.
Formative times.
Why do a book?
There's so much involved.
You have to prioritize it, you have to promote
it.
Why do a book?
What does it mean to you and what do you hope
it will do in terms of impact for people who
read it?
Rich Paul: I think a book brings a seriousness
to it.
Instead of just doing a visual.
I think when people really sit down and read
a book, you can really dive into its chapters
and read it again and go back.
And so the book form was important.
The timing of it was important.
You look at the state of the world.
How our youth sees the world today, the different
perceptions that people may feel like they
have without being able to have someone hear
them.
I wanted to write a book to where I shared
my experiences, I shared my journey, but also
wanting to let people know that you're being
heard, and not only are you being heard, you
can be in a different place as long as you
stay in the moment.
I know it may seem dark and gray and bleak
and challenging, but you tend to think that
everyone's paying attention to you and what
you've got going on.
And so you get discouraged, but in reality,
they're not.
Everyone has their own problems.
Just get through yours.
Tim Ferriss: Totally.
Rich Paul: Get through them, continue to push,
continue to persevere, and you can end up
in a different spot.
I wanted to give kids that example and just
people in general.
Regardless of race, regardless of gender,
I just wanted to give you that example.
And it was the right time for me because I'm
at a place to where I'm honestly comfortable
enough, and I feel like I've accomplished
enough to allow people in because today people
want to be Rich Paul.
They want to be a better version, and they
want to do the things that I do.
They want to be an agent because of me.
Once I got to that point, I wanted to help
them understand who I really am and why I
do the things I do.
Because it's very misleading to say, "Oh,
this guy became a top agent.
He'd done $4 billion in contracts and he didn't
go to college."
Well, that could —
Tim Ferriss: There's more to it.
Rich Paul: Yeah, that could leave a kid like
he playing Mortal Kombat, it's like just sitting
there like dizzy.
I wanted to give them an example and an understanding
and paint a picture through storytelling that
they see themselves in that same mirror and
like, "Damn, I don't have to go out here and
rob somebody.
I don't have to go out here and kill somebody.
I don't have to go out here and feel like
I'm not being heard.
He had the same problems I did.
Wow.
I see myself in that."
And here's an example that I see every day.
I can see him, I can touch them, whatever.
I'm accessible to people.
I like to talk to people when they see me
out in the street and it's like, wow.
So that was encouraging for me.
What I didn't want to do is write a puff piece.
And that's what I said to my team.
I said, "If I do a book, it will not be a
puff piece.
I don't want to write a book on, 'Look what
I did.
Look how much money I made.'
I don't need to do that."
That could be the second book.
That can't be the first book.
The first book, people need to know who I
am at my core, what I've been through.
And it was therapeutic for me, and I'm glad
I did it.
It was something that I'm proud of.
And hopefully when people read the book, they
feel inspired by it.
Tim Ferriss: And the subtitle is great also.
I mean, I love everything about it.
I mean, Lucky Me: A Memoir of Changing the
Odds, and certainly you've demonstrated that.
And just a few closing questions for you.
The first is, if you could put anything on
a billboard, this is metaphorically speaking,
just to get a message out to billions of people.
Could be an image, could be a quote, could
be a word, could be something that's inspired
you, anything at all.
What might you put on that billboard?
Do you have any ideas?
Rich Paul: I would put, "Kindness never hurts.
Love is never wasted.
Unity starts with you.
Trust makes it possible.
Community is a mentality, and honesty keeps
it real."
And I think you need all those things to change
the way people are living today for the better.
You need all those things to help uplift somebody.
You need all those things to unite and elaborate,
and you need all those things to be Klutch.
Tim Ferriss: Rich, I've really enjoyed spending
time with you.
People can find you on Instagram @RichPaul,
Twitter @RichPaul4, the number four, and certainly
they can find the new book Lucky Me: A Memoir
of Changing the Odds, everywhere fine books
are sold.
Is there anything else you'd like to say or
anything you'd like to ask of my audience?
Anything at all you'd like to add before we
wind up?
Rich Paul: I want to thank you for having
me on.
I know you're not into sports like that, but
obviously I'm doing something right to get
your attention, so I'm happy for that.
And to the audience, you don't have to be
in sports, don't feel like I have to be in
sports to read this book.
You don't even have to know how to spell sports
per se.
And I think that it's important to really
care about what other people are going through
despite what society teaches us.
I think it's important to really dive into
other people's experiences because it allows
you to try to have a better perspective and
a better understanding of people.
I'm glad to have matured to the point to where
I can honestly say that, because I grew up
in an environment where we didn't care about
nothing at all.
Tim Ferriss: Well, Rich, I can barely spell
sports, but I can spell human, and your story
is intensely human.
I think it will resonate with a lot of readers
and it's a hero's journey of changing the
odds.
I'm very excited to see what it'll do in the
world.
Lucky Me: A Memoir of Changing the Odds is
the book, everyone.
Please check it out.
And thank you so much for taking the time,
Rich.
Rich Paul: Thanks, Tim, I appreciate it.
Tim Ferriss: This has been a lot of fun.
And to everybody listening, we'll include
links in the show notes as usual to everything
at tim.blog/podcast.
Until next time, be just a bit kinder than
is necessary to others and to yourself, and
thanks for tuning in.